[Music]
Christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
16 year old Russian ice skater Camila
valeeva channels her inner Wednesday
Adams and the whole thing just went
viral
why should I bother telling you anything
you've already decided I'm lying yeah
remember this scene from Netflix's
Wednesday
[Music]
well Camila recreated it on the ice and
nailed it all the way down to the hand
motions Gothic party dress and long
black pigtails
[Music]
something tells us Wednesday would be
proud
[Music]
of course Jenna Ortega plays the title
character in the hit show and her
choreography has taken the World by
storm she dances to the cramps Google
muck in the show but over on Tick Tock
fans switched it up and show off their
moves to Lady Gaga's Bloody Mary
[Music]
that's Camila Cabello giving it a go
Lisa Rinna and her hubby Harry Hamlin
did it too
Jenna Dewan slayed the moves
[Music]
even Lady Gaga herself put her own spin
on it
[Music]
Jen opened up on The Tonight Show
recently about choreographing the
routine after a chat with the director
Tim Burton he came to my trailer about
two days before we shot it and said hey
Jenna so I know you said that you wanted
to choreograph the self because ever
this yourself because like I know you
got it I trust you and I said oh yeah
you know it's all so good and I had not
gone over it at all yeah that dance came
together last minute Jenna said she
spent two days researching for the scene
I was kicking myself I I felt like such
a fool I was like I'm not a dancer and
then on the day I thought all right well
I'm just gonna do it
well we know what happened it went viral
into a teenage
mug Wednesday is the second most watched
Series in Netflix history and leading up
to the show's Premiere Luis Guzman and
Fred Armisen opened up to ET about how
perfect Jenna is as the iconic character
she was so spot on she's too hard and I
was really really proud of her I wanted
to compliment it by being even more
festered because she was totally
Wednesday and at the premiere Jenna
dished on the hard work it took to bring
Wednesday to life I started cello and
fencing a couple months before we
started production and then I I
continued throughout the the eight
months of shooting in Romania so I would
do the 12 14 hour work day and then I
would have
cello and fencing at the end of my day
[Music]